The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MIT at
OpenCourseWare@oce.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, in that
case, let's get started.
As usual, I like
to begin by giving
a review of what we
talked about last time.
This time on slides instead
of on the blackboard.
We're talking mainly
about relativistic energy,
or relativistic energy and
momentum, and pressure,
sometimes.
The key equation is probably
the most famous equation
in physics, Einstein's
e equals m c squared.
And I gave some
numerical examples.
I actually looked up some
more numbers since then,
when I was revising
the lecture notes.
So these are slightly
more up to date.
But it's still true that
if you could burn matter
at the rate of one
kilogram per hour,
you would have about
one and a half times
the total power
output of the world.
And that's apparently
still valid in 2011.
I only had 2008 figures,
actually, at the lecture
last time.
And if you imagine the
15-gallon tank of gasoline,
and you could figure out how
much that-- what it's mass is,
and convert that to
energy, it turns out
that a 15-gallon
tank of gasoline
could power the world for about
two and half days, if you could
convert all of it into energy.
The catch, of course, is
that we can't convert matter
into energy.
We can't get around the problem
that, at least at the energies
that we deal with,
baryon number.
And that number of protons
and neutrons is conserved,
so we can't make protons
and neutrons disappear.
And that means that we're
limited in what we can do.
In particular, one of the most
efficient things we can do
is fission uranium 235.
But when uranium 235 undergoes
fission, less than 1/10
of 1% of the mass is
actually converted
into energy, which is why we
can't actually avail ourselves
of these fantastic
numbers that would apply,
if we could literally just
convert matter into energy.
We went on to talk about
the relativistic definitions
of energy and momentum,
and how they come together
to form a Lorentz four vector,
and the underlying theme here
is that we consider ourselves
users of special relativity.
Most of you I know have taken
special relativity courses,
and for those of you who
have, this is a review.
For those you who have not,
and there are some of those
also, no need to panic.
I intend to tell you
every fact that you
need to know about
special relativity.
I won't tell you how
to derive them all,
but I'll tell you all you'll
need to know for this class.
So in particular, it's
useful for this class
to recognize that energy and
momentum can be put together
into a four vector, where
the zeroth component
is the energy divided
by the speed of light.
And the three spatial components
are just the three components
of the spatial
momentum, although they
have to be defined
relativistically.
The relativistic
definition of momentum,
at least how it
relates to velocity,
is that it's equal to
gamma times the rest
mass times the velocity, where
gamma is the famous factor
that we've been
seeing all along when
we've talked about relativity.
The Lorentz
contraction factor, one
over the square root of 1
minus v squared over c squared.
The energy of a particle,
relativistically,
is the same gamma, times m
0 times c squared, and it
can also be written as
the square root of m 0
c squared squared, plus
the momentum squared,
times c squared.
Since the momentum
forms a four vector,
its Lorentz and variant square
should be Lorentz and variant,
and that means that
the momentum squared
minus p 0 squared should be the
same in all inertial reference
frames.
And that's just
equal when you put
in what p 0 means,
the momentum squared
minus the energy squared,
divided by c 0 squared.
And to know what value it's
equal to in all frames,
it's efficient to know what
it's equal to in one frame.
And the one frame
where we do know
what it's equal to is the
rest frame of a particle.
So in the rest frame,
the momentum vanishes,
and the energy is
just m 0 c squared.
So in the rest frame,
we can evaluate this,
and we get minus m
0 c squared squared.
And that means that has to
be the value in every frame.
And this in fact is
the easy way to derive
the relationship between
energy and momentum.
If we go back, the
equation we had
relating energy and momentum is
really exactly that equation,
rearranged.
Just to give an example of how
this works, when we actually
have energy exchanges,
I pointed out
that we could talk about the
energy of a hydrogen atom.
And because energy and
mass are equivalent,
the hydrogen atom clearly
has a little bit less energy
than an isolated proton,
plus an isolated electron.
Because when you
bring them together
there's a binding energy,
and that binding energy
is called delta e, and has
a value of 13.6 electron
volts for the ground
state of hydrogen.
So that tells us the
mass of an hydrogen atom
is not the sum of
the two masses,
but rather has this
correction factor,
because we've taken out a little
bit of energy for the binding.
And that means we've taken
out a little bit of mass.
OK, then we talked about the
mass density of radiation
and how-- building up to how
that will affect the universe.
And we said that the
mass density of radiation
is just the energy density
divided by c squared.
And that can be taken, really,
as a definition of what
we call relativistic
mass, and hence
relativistic mass density.
But the important point is
that this mass density actually
does gravitate the
same as any other mass
density of the same value.
It really does create
gravity in the same way.
Now I mentioned that things are
much more complicated if you
want to talk about the
gravitational field produced
by a single moving particle.
That's asymmetric, the
velocity of the particle
shows up in the equations that
describe the metric surrounding
a single moving particle.
But if you have a gas
of particles moving
at high velocities, where
the velocities nonetheless
average to zero, which
tends to happen, in a gas
at least in the rest
frame of the gas.
Then that gas will produce
gravitational fields,
just like a static mass density.
Where the mass density is this
relativistic energy divided
by c squared, the relativistic
definition of the mass density.
It's also useful to know
that the photon-- if we want
to describe it as a particle,
is a particle of zero rest mass.
Which means that it
can never be at rest,
it always moves at
the speed of light.
And it also means that its
energy can be arbitrarily
small, because the energy
is proportional of momentum,
and the momentum of a photon
can be as small as you like.
For giving frequency, of
course, the energy of a photon
is fixed.
It's h times nu but
if you're allowed
to vary the frequency,
which you can do if you just
look at it in
different frames, you
can make the energy
as small as you like.
And the famous equation
then, p squared minus e
squared c squared, which
would have on the right,
minus m 0 squared
c to the 4th m 0
squared c squared, excuse me--
has zero on the right hand
side, because m 0
is 0 And that means
that for photons, the energy is
just the speed of light times
the momentum.
And that's a famous
relationship that photons obey.
Now, thinking about
how this gas of photons
will behave in the universe,
we realized immediately
that it does not
behave the same way
as a mass density of ordinary
non-relativistic particles.
Which is what we have
been dealing with to date.
The important difference
is that in both cases,
the number density falls
off like 1 over a cubed,
as the universe expands,
these particles are not
created and destroyed
in significant numbers,
they just persevere.
So the number density of either
non-relativistic particles,
or photons, just falls off
like one over the volume,
as the volume increases and
the number density dilutes.
But what makes photons
different from non-relativistic
particles, is that a
non-relativistic particle
will maintain the
energy of that particle
as the universe
expands, but photons
will redshift as the
universe expands.
So each photon will
itself lose energy.
And it loses energy proportional
to one over the scale factor.
And that's just because the
frequency shift proportionally
to the scale factor.
And that means that
the energy per photon
shifts, because
quantum mechanically
we know that the
energy of a photon
is proportional
to its frequency.
So if the frequency
redshifts so must the energy.
In exactly the same
way, 1 over a f t.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: You said
previously that neutrinos
behave like radiation
in the sense
that theta energy
falls is 1 over a.
What is it about them
that makes this happen?
Because there are also particles
with standard kinetic energy,
right?
PROFESSOR: OK, the question,
in case you didn't hear it,
is why-- how did
neutrinos fit in here?
I've made the claim that
neutrinos act like radiation
in the early universe, but
neutrinos have a non-zero mass,
so they should obey the
standard formulas for particles
with nonzero masses.
The answer to that
is-- there is,
I think, a simple answer,
which is that as long
as the energy is large
compared to the mass,
particles with masses will still
act like massless particles.
It doesn't really matter
if the mass is zero or not,
the key thing, really,
is this equation.
So if the term on
the right hand side
is small compared to either
of the two on the left,
it's not much different
from being zero.
And that's what
happens for neutrinos
in the early universe.
And we'll see soon that if
you go to early enough times,
it's true even for
electron-positron pairs.
They will also act
like radiation.
Any particle will
act like radiation
as long as the energy is large
compared to the rest energy.
So getting back
to the discussion
of the early universe, if
the energy of each photon
falls off like one
over the scale factor,
and the number density falls off
like one over the scale factor
cubed, it means that
the energy density,
and hence, the mass
density of radiation
will fall off like one
over a to the fourth,
in contrast to the one over
a cubed, that we found when
we were talking about
non-relativistic matter.
And that, of course, is
going to make a difference.
Because those issues play a
key role in our discussions
about how the universe evolved.
An important feature,
which we see immediately,
is that if we extrapolate
backwards in time,
since the radiation mass density
is falling off like one over a
to the fourth, and the
matter density is falling off
like one over a cubed, it means
that as you go back in time,
the radiation becomes
more and more important
relative to the matter, by
factor of the scale factor.
So if we go back far
enough, we will even
find a time when the
mass density in radiation
equaled the mass density
in non-relativistic matter.
And we calculated about
when that would be.
We said that the energy
density in radiation today
is given by this number, 7
times 10 to the minus 14,
joules per meter cubed.
And I just gave you this
number, I didn't derive it yet.
We will derive it,
probably later today.
But for now, we're
just accepting it.
And that implies
we can calculate
from that the ratio
of the mass densities
in radiation and
ordinary matter.
Here, we use the fact
that ordinary matter
can be described
by having an omega
ratio to the critical
density of about 0.3.
And we know how to calculate
the critical density,
and that allowed us to calculate
the density of ordinary matter.
And then this ratio turned
out to be 3.1 times 10
to the minus four.
So radiation in
today's universe is
almost negligible
in its contribution
to the overall energy
balance, compared
to non-relativistic matter.
But if you
extrapolate backwards,
we know that this ratio will
vary as one over the scale
factor.
And we could figure
out what constants
to put this equation by
putting in the right constant,
so that this equation gives
us the right value today.
Where the right value today is
3.1 times 10 to the minus four.
And notice that
this works, if we
let t be equal to t sub
zero, this factors one
and we get 3.1 times
10 to the minus four.
So these two factors
together they
have t zero and the 3.1
times 10 to the minus four,
are just the right
factors to put in
to give us the right
constant of proportionality
in that equation.
Having this
equation, we can then
ask, how far back do we
have to go, how much we have
to change t, for
the ratio to be one?
And that's a
straightforward calculation.
And the ratio of the a is
then just one over 3.1 times
10 to the minus four, or 3,200.
So if we talk about it in
terms of a redshift, which
is how astronomers always talk
about distances, or times,
we're talking about going
back to a redshift of 3,200.
We can figure out what time,
then, corresponds to also,
if we know how a f
t depends on time.
And we do, approximately.
For this calculation,
I assume for now, we
could do better
later, and we will--
but I assume for now
that we could just
treat the period between matter
radiation equality, so-called t
x and now as being
entirely described
by a matter-dominated universe.
That's only a crude
approximation,
but it will get us the
right order of magnitude.
And we'll learn how to do
better later in the course.
So if we assume that, then t x
is just this number to the 3/2
power, cancelling the 2/3, times
the age of universe, t naught.
And that turned out to
be about 75,000 years.
So somewhere in the range of
100,000 years, 50,000 years,
is the time in the history of
the universe when radiation
ceased to be more
important than matter.
And for earlier times than
that, the radiation dominated.
And that's what we refer to as
the radiation dominated era.
Any questions?
OK, now I think we get
on to what is really
the important subject that
we want to understand,
and most of this you did
yourself on the homework.
But I'll summarize
the argument here.
We want to understand
what this tells us
about the Friedmann Equations.
And first, we'd
like to understand
what it says about pressure.
Because it turns
out that pressure
is the crucial
issue in determining
how fast row falls
off as a expands.
So if row is proportional
to one over a cubed,
we can just differentiate
that, putting
in a constant proportionality
temporarily, just
to keep track of
what we're doing.
Since we know how to
differentiate qualities
and we're less familiar
with how to differentiate
proportionalities.
But what we find immediately,
is that row dot is then minus 3,
where that 3 is that 3,
times a dot over a times row.
On the other hand, if
row of t falls like one
over a to the fourth,
row dot is minus 4 times
a dot over a times row,
just by differentiation.
So we get different
expressions from row dot,
between radiation and matter.
And we want to explore
the consequences
of that difference.
It's related to the
pressure of the gas,
because we can relate
the pressure to row dot.
Because we know that
as a gas expands,
it loses energy, which is
just equal in amount to pdV.
And we illustrated this by
a piston thought experiment,
but it's true in general.
So we can apply this famous
formula, dU equals minus pdV,
to a patch of the
expanding universe.
And by a patch I mean some fixed
region and coordinate space.
So the total energy in that
region of coordinate space
will be the physical
volume, which
will be a cubed times
the coordinate volume.
Which is going to cancel out
of this equation on both sides.
So it's a cubed times
the coordinate volume
times the energy density,
which is row c squared.
The rate of change
of that is Du.
And then on the
right hand side, we
have minus p minus
b times dV, which
is the rate of change
of a cubed, again
times the coordinate volume
that we're talking about.
But that will cancel out on
the two sides of the equation.
So this is really
just a description
for the universe of the dU
equals minus pdV equation.
And this can just be rearranged,
expanding the time derivatives,
to give us row dot, and
we get minus 3 a dot
over a, times row
plus p over c squared.
So this tells us how to relate
row dot to the pressure.
And it tells us that the
formula that we started
with a long time ago, which
just said that row fell off
like 1 over a cubed, was
synonymous with saying
the pressure is zero, for a gas
of non-relativistic particles,
the pressure is negligible.
But for radiation,
clearly if we're
going to get a four
instead of a three,
the pressure will
be non-negligible.
And in fact, it implies
that the pressure
is exactly equal to
one third of the energy
density for a gas of radiation.
OK, knowing that, we can now
look back at the Friedmann
equations and ask,
how do they stand up?
Are they still consistent, or
do we have to modify something?
And this is really
the crucial point.
What we know are
these three equations,
which are the two
Friedmann equations
and the equation for row dot.
And we could see immediately
that those equations are not
independent of each other.
The easiest thing
to see is that if we
start with the top equation,
we could differentiate it.
And since the top
equation has a dot in it,
when we differentiate, we'll get
an equation for a double dot.
But the equation will
also involve row dot,
if we take the time derivative
of that top equation.
But if we know
what row dot is, we
could put that
in, and in the end
we'll get an equation for
a double dot by itself.
And it will in fact
agree with the equation
on the middle line.
Again, things would
be inconsistent.
Things are consistent, we
didn't make any mistakes.
If we derive the
equation for a double dot
by using the first and
third of those equations,
then we'll get the second
of those equations.
But the catch is
that now we want
to modify the third
of those equations,
the equations for row dot.
And then the Friedmann
equations as we've
written them will not
be consistent anymore.
Because we'll have a different
equation for row dot,
we'll get a different
equation for a double dot.
So we have to decide what gives.
What can we change to make
everything consistent?
And here, the rigorous
way of proceeding
is to look at general
relativity and see what it says,
and the answer we're
going to write down
is exactly what general
relativity says.
But we can motivate
the answer in, I think,
a pretty sensible
way, by noticing
that as the universe
expands, we'd
expect the energy density
to vary continuously,
because energies are conserved.
And we also expect a dot
to vary continuously,
because basically, the
mechanics of the universe
are like ton's laws.
And velocities don't
change discontinuously.
You can apply a
force, and that causes
velocities to have
a rate of change.
But velocities don't
change instantaneously,
unless you somehow
apply an infinite force.
And the same thing will
be true with the universe.
On the other hand, accelerations
can change instantaneously.
You could change the force
acting on a particle,
in principle, as
fast as you want,
and the acceleration
of the particle
will change at that same rate.
So if we look at
these equations,
we would expect that the first
equation and the third equation
would not be allowed to
involve the pressure.
Because the pressure basically
is a measure of a force.
Pressures can change
instantaneously.
So what you need to
do, if we're going
to make these equations
consistent in the presence
of pressure-- which changes
the row dot equation,
the only equation we can
change is the second one.
And then we can
ask ourselves, what
do we have to change it to make
the three equations consistent?
And this is what you
looked at on your homework.
And the answer is that
the a double dot equation
has to be modified
to give the equation
at the bottom of
the screen here.
And this is the correct form
of the a double dot equation
in cosmology.
And this is what we'll be
using for the rest of the term,
this is exactly what you would
get from general relativity.
As long as we're talking
about homogeneous
and isotropic universes,
this formula as exact
as far as we know.
OK, any questions about that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why when we derive
that equation do we use--
PROFESSOR: This equation?
AUDIENCE: Or the one above that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We use dU
equals minus pdV?
I mean, I agree with
that, but couldn't we
use a more complete version?
Like, the complete
version of the first law
of thermodynamics, that
dU equals TDS minus pdV.
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah.
The question was when we wrote
down dU equals minus pdV,
why did we not include
a plus TDS term here,
which could also be relevant.
The answer is that
for the applications
we're interested in--
you're quite right,
it could be important,
but for the applications
that we're interested in,
which is the expanding
gas in the universe, the
expanding gas in the universe
will be making use of this fact.
It really does expand
adiabatically, that is,
there's nothing
putting heat in or out,
and everything is remaining very
close to thermal equilibrium,
which means that entropy does
not spontaneously change.
So the TDS term we will be
assuming is very, very small,
and that's accurate.
And you're right, if
that were not the case,
there would be further
complications in terms
of figuring out what row dot is.
Let me point out here that
this equation actually
does contain a somewhat
startling perhaps fact
about gravity it says
that in the context
of general relativity.
And that's really the
context that we're in,
even though we haven't learned
a lot of general relativity.
But it says that in the
context of general relativity,
pressures, as well
as mass densities,
contribute to the
gravitational field.
A double dot is
basically a measure
of how fast gravity is
slowing down the universe.
And this says that
there's a pressure.
It can also help to
slow down the universe.
Meaning that pressure itself can
create a gravitational field.
In the early universe,
where we go back
to this radiation
dominated period,
we know that the pressure is
one third of the energy density.
That says that
this pressure term
is the same size exactly
as the mass density term.
So in the radiation
dominated phase,
the pressure is just
as important in effect
for slowing down the universe
as is the mass density.
In today's universe
it's negligible.
Well, we'll come back that.
The dark energy has a
non-trivial pressure,
but the pressure of ordinary
matter in today's universe
is negligible.
The other important
fact about this equation
is that energy densities,
so far as we know,
are always positive.
We don't know for sure what
the ultimate laws of physics
are, but for all the laws
of physics that we know,
energy densities are positive.
On the other hand,
pressures actually
can be negative for
some kinds of material.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about how
to get a negative
pressure later.
But this formula tells us
that positive pressures
act the same way as
positive mass densities,
creating an attractive
gravitational field which
slows down the expansion
of the universe.
But if there could be a material
with a negative pressure,
this same equation, which
would presumably still hold,
and believe it
does, would tell us
that that negative
pressure would actually
cause the universe to
accelerate, because
of its gravitational effects.
Now, we're not talking
about the mechanical effects
of the pressure.
Mechanical effects
of pressure only
show up when there are
pressure gradients, when
the pressure is uneven.
So the very large air
pressure in this room,
which really is quite
large, we don't feel all,
because it's acting
equally in all directions.
Uniform pressures do
not produce forces.
So the mechanical effects of the
pressure in the early universe,
which we're assuming is
completely homogeneous,
is zilch.
There is no mechanical effect.
But what we're seeing
in this equation
is a gravitational effect
caused by the pressure.
And it's obviously
gravitational,
business the effect is
proportional to Newton's
capital G, a
constant determining
the strength of gravity.
So the equation is telling
us that a positive pressure
creates a gravitational
attraction, which
would cause the universe to
slow down in its expansion.
But a negative
pressure would produce
a gravitational repulsion,
which would cause universe
to speed up.
And we now know that,
today-- in fact,
for the last five billion
years or so-- our universe
itself is actually accelerating
under the influence
of something.
And the only
explanation we have is
that the something that's
causing the universe
to accelerate is the
repulsive gravity caused
by some kind of a negative
pressure material.
And that negative
pressure material
is what we call the dark energy.
And we'll talk a little
more later about what it is.
It's very likely
just vacuum energy.
But we'll come back to
that later in the course.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When we looked at
the toy example of the piston
in the cavity, the
pressure of the gas
was pushing outwards against
the wall of the container.
But we can't have that view
of the universe, really,
because there's no
exteriors in the universe.
PROFESSOR: There's
no walls, right.
AUDIENCE: So how should we view
pressure in the sense that--
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah.
OK, the question is, in our toy
problem involving the piston,
we had walls for the
pressure to push against.
And that was where
the energy went.
It went into pushing the walls.
When we're talking about the
universe, there are no walls.
How does that analogy work?
What plays the
role of the walls?
And the answer, I think, is
that the role of the walls, when
we're talking about the
universe, first of all, you
can ignore it if you just
took in a small region.
You could still just
say, the small region
is pushing out on the
regions around it.
And I think that's enough
to make the logic clear.
But it still leaves open
the question of, ultimately,
where does this energy go?
So saying it goes
from here to there
doesn't help you
unless you know where
it goes after it goes
from and there and there.
So you might want to ask
the question more generally,
where does the energy
ultimately end up?
And then I think the
answer is that it ends up
in gravitational
potential energy.
You could certainly build
a toy model, where you just
have a gas in a finite region,
self-contained under gravity.
And then you'd have to make
up some kind of a mechanism
to cause it to expand.
But when you cause
it to expand, you'll
be pulling particles
apart, which
are attracting each
other gravitationally.
And that means
you'll be increasing
the gravitational
potential energy
as you pull the gas apart.
So I think, ultimately, the
answer is the energy imbalance
that we seem to be
seeing here is taken up
by the gravitational field
so that, all in all, energy
still conserved.
Any other questions?
OK, in that case, let us
continue on the blackboard.
OK, first thing I
want to look at it
is just the behavior of a
radiation-dominated flat
universe.
So a flat universe
is going to obey
H squared equals
8 pi over 3 G rho,
and then the potential minus
kc squared over a squared.
Hard to write dotted
lines on the blackboard.
But this potential term is
not there, because k equals 0.
We're talking about
the flat case.
So for a flat case, we could
just express H in terms of rho.
And we know how rho
behaves for radiation.
Rho falls off as
1/a to the fourth.
So H squared is proportional
to 1/a to the fourth.
That means that H itself is
proportional to 1/a squared.
So we can do that.
a-dot over a is equal to
some constant over a squared,
a-dot over a being H. And now
we can multiply both sides
by a, of course.
And we get a-dot is equal
to a constant over a.
And this we can integrate.
The way to integrate is
to put all the a's on one
side and all of the
dt's on the other side.
So we get ada,
writing this as da/dt.
So ada is equal to
the constant times dt.
And then, as we've
done before, when
we're talking about matter,
it's the same calculation there.
I just did different
power of a appears
so we'd know how to do it.
Integrating, we get 1/2a squared
is equal to the constant times
t, and then plus a new constant
of integration, constant prime.
Now we make the same argument
as we've made in the past.
We have not yet
said anything that
determines how our clocks
are going to be set.
So we can choose to set our
clocks in the standard way,
which is to set our
clocks so that t equals
0 corresponds to the moment
where a is equal to 0.
And if a is going to be equal
to 0 when t is equal to 0,
it means constant prime
is going to be equal to 0.
So by choosing the
value of constant prime,
we really are just
determining how
we're going to set
our clocks, how
we're going to
choose the 0 of time.
And we'll do that by setting
constant prime equal to 0.
And then we get
the famous formula
for a radiation-dominated
universe, a of t
is just proportional to
the square root of t,
or t to the 1/2 power.
And this is for a
radiation-dominated flat
universe, replacing
the t to the 2/3
that we have for the
matter-dominated flat universe.
Once we know that
a is proportional
to the square root of t--
and for the flat universe,
the constant proportionality
mean nothing, by the way.
It's not that we haven't
been smart enough
to figure out what it is.
It really has no
meaning whatever.
You could set it equal
to whatever you want,
and it just determines
your definition
of the notch, your
definition of how you're
going to measure the
comoving coordinate system.
Once we know this, we should
know pretty much everything.
So in particular,
we can calculate
h, which a-dot over a.
And the constant
proportionality drops
when we compute a-dot over a.
As we expect, it has no meaning.
So it should not appear in
the equation for anything
that does have physical meaning.
So H is just 1/2t,
the 1/2 here coming
from differentiating
the t the 1/2 power.
We can also compute
the horizon distance.
So the physical horizon
distance, l sub p horizon,
where p stands for physical,
is equal to the scale factor
times the coordinate
horizon distance.
And the coordinate
horizon distance
is just the total
coordinate distance
that light could travel from
the beginning of the universe.
And we know the coordinate
velocity of light
is c divided by a.
So we just integrate that to get
the total coordinate distance.
So it's the integral
from 0 to t of c
over a of t prime dt prime.
And since a of t is
just t to the 1/2,
this is a trivial
integral to do.
And the answer is
2 times c times t.
So in a radiation-dominated
universe,
the horizon's distance
is twice c times t.
For a static universe,
the horizon distance
would just be c times t.
It would just be the distance
light can travel in time t,
but more complicated in
an expanding universe.
For the matter-dominated
case, we
discovered that the
horizon distance was 3ct,
if you remember.
For the radiation-dominated
case, it's 2ct.
And finally, an
important equation
is that, going back to
here, where we started,
this equation relates H to rho.
We found out that,
merely by knowing
the universe is
radiation-dominated,
without even caring about
what kind of radiation
it is, how much neutrinos,
how much photons, whatever--
doesn't matter-- merely
by knowing the universe
is radiation-dominated, we were
able to tell that H is 1/2t.
And if we know what H
is, that formula tells us
we also know what rho is.
So without even knowing
what kind of radiation
is contributing, we know that,
for a radiation-dominated
universe, rho is just
equal to 3 over 32
pi Newton's constant G times
time, little t, squared.
It's rather amazing that we
can write down that formula
without even knowing what kind
of radiation is contributing.
But as long as that
radiation falls
off as 1 over the scale
factor to the fourth,
and as long as we know
the universe is flat,
then we know what that
energy density has to be.
This is crucial
here, by the way.
The energy could be
anything if we did not
assume that the
universe was flat.
OK, any questions about this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If we assumed
that it was almost flat,
would we be able to
have any bounds on it?
PROFESSOR: OK, question
is, if we assumed
that it was almost
flat, would we
be able to have
any bounds on it?
The answer is, yeah, if
you were quantitative
about what you meant
by "almost flat,"
you could know how almost true
that formula would have to be.
OK, if there are
no other questions,
I want to switch
gears slightly now
and go back to talk about some
of the basic underlying physics
that we are going to need,
and in particular, the physics
of black-body radiation.
So this is really just a little
chapter of a stat mech course
that we're inserting
here, because we need it.
And because it comes
from another course,
we're not going try to
do it in complete detail.
But I'll try to write down
formulas that make sense.
And that will give us what
we need to know to proceed.
So that will be the goal.
So what is black-body radiation?
The physical phenomenon
is that, if one imagines
a box with a cavity
in it-- that's
supposed to be a box
with a cavity in it,
in case you can't recognize the
picture-- if the box is held
at some uniform temperature
t-- t is temperature--
then is claimed and
verified experimentally
that the cavity will fill up
with radiation-- in this case,
we're really just talking about
electromagnetic radiation--
the calving will fill up with
electromagnetic radiation
whose characteristics
would be determined solely
by that temperature
t and will therefore
be totally independent of the
material that makes up the box.
Roughly speaking,
I think the way
to think about it is to say
that the box will fill up
with radiation at temperature t.
And saying that the
radiation has temperature t
is enough to completely
describe the radiation.
It doesn't matter
what kind of a box
that radiation is sitting in.
So the box will fill with
radiation at temperature t.
And that radiation is
called black-body radiation.
Like many things in physics,
it has a variety of names,
just to confuse us all.
So it's also called
cavity radiation,
which makes a lot
of sense, given
the description we just gave.
And it's also sometimes called
just thermal equilibrium
radiation.
This is radiation
at temperature t.
I haven't really justified
the word "black-body"
radiation yet, so let me
try to do that quickly.
The reason why it can be called
black-body radiation-- and this
will be important for
some things in cosmology;
I'm not sure if it will
be important to us or not,
but certainly important to
know-- the reason why it's
called black-body radiation is
because we imagine inserting
into this cavity a black
body, in the literal sense.
What is the literal
sense of a black body?
It's a body which is
black in the sense
that all radiation that
hits it is absorbed.
Now, this black body
is still going to glow.
If you heat a piece
of iron or something
to very high temperatures,
you see it glow.
That glow is not reflection.
That glow is emission
by the hot atoms
in the piece of
iron or whatever.
Emission is different
from reflection.
When we say it
absorbs everything,
we mean it does not
reflect anything.
But it will still admit
by thermal de-excitation.
The crucial distinction between
reflection and thermal emission
is that reflection
is instantaneous.
When a light beam comes
in, if it's reflected,
it just goes back
out instantaneously.
Emission, thermal emission,
is a slower process.
Atoms get excited,
and eventually, they
de-excite and emit radiation.
So it takes time.
And that's the distinction.
We're going to assume that
this body is black in the sense
that there's no reflection.
OK, now we're going to
make use of the fact
that we know that thermal
equilibrium works.
That is, if you let any
isolated system sit long enough,
it will approach a unique
state of thermal equilibrium
determined by its constituents,
which you've put in
to begin with, but otherwise
independent of how exactly
you arrange those constituents.
So if we put in, for
example, a cold black body,
it will start to get
harder, warming up
to the same temperature
as everything else.
If we put in an
extra hot black body,
it would emit energy
and start to cool down
to the temperature
of everything else.
But eventually,
this black body will
be at the same temperature
as everything else.
And we're going to be assuming
here that the box itself
is being held at some
fixed temperature t.
So wherever energy
exchange occurs
because of this
black body, it will
be absorbed by
whatever is holding
the outer box at the
fixed temperature.
So in the end, if
we wait long enough,
this black body is going to
acquire the same temperature
as everything else and
hold that temperature.
Now, if it's holding
that temperature,
it means that the energy input
to the box, to the black body,
will have to be the
same as the energy
output of the black body.
Now, the black body is going
to be absorbing radiation,
because we have
radiation here, and we
said that any radiation
that hits it is absorbed.
That was the
definition of "black."
So it's clearly
absorbing energy.
If it's not going
to be heating up--
and we know that it's
not, because it's
in thermal equilibrium; the
temperature will remain fixed--
in order for it
to not heat up, it
has to radiate energy, as well.
And the energy it radiates
has to be exactly the same
as the energy it's
absorbing once it
reaches thermal equilibrium.
So in equilibrium, the black
body, BB, radiates at same rate
that it absorbs energy.
This radiation process
is this slow process
of thermal emission.
There are atoms inside this
black body that are excited.
Those atoms will
de-excite over time,
releasing photons
that will go off.
And the important thing
about that slow mechanism
is that, if we imagine
taking this black body out
of its cavity, but not waiting
long enough for its temperature
to change-- so we'll
assume its temperature
is still the same, t.
So this is a picture of the same
black body at temperature t,
but now outside the cavity.
Its radiation rate is not
going to change when we take it
outside the cavity, because the
radiation was caused by things
happening inside the black body,
which are not changed when we
put it in or out of the cavity.
So it will continue to radiate
at exactly the same rate
that it was radiating
when it was in the cavity.
And that means it's
going to radiate
at exactly the same
rate as the energy
that it would have
absorbed if it were bathed
by this black-body radiation.
So essentially, it means it
will emit black-body radiation
with exactly the intensity that
the black-body radiation would
have on the outside if
the black body were still
inside the cavity.
So it radiates with exactly the
same intensity as the energy
that it would receive if
it were inside the cavity.
And furthermore, you
could even elaborate a bit
on his argument to show that
the radiation that it radiates
has exactly the same spectrum,
exactly the same decomposition
into wavelengths, as
the black-body radiation
inside the cavity.
And the way to see
that is to imagine
surrounding this black body by
absorption filters that only
let through certain frequencies.
And the point is that, no
matter what frequencies
you limit going
through this filter,
you have to stay in equilibrium.
It will never get
hotter or colder.
So that means that each
frequency by itself
has to balance, has to have
exactly the same emission
as it would have abortion
if the black body were just
exposed to black-body
radiation surrounding it.
So it radiates
black-body radiation.
And the intensity
and spectrum must
match what we call black-body
or cavity radiation.
So the cavity radiation
has to exactly mimic
the radiation emitted
by this black body.
And that's the
motivation for calling it
black-body radiation.
Now, if this black body
absorbed some radiation
and reflected some, then it
would emit different radiation.
So it is important
that this body
be black, in the sense that
it doesn't reflect anything.
All radiation hitting
it is absorbed.
And only under
that assumption do
we know exactly what
it's going to emit.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So is this
only true for right
after you take it out?
PROFESSOR: Well, it will start
to cool after you take it out.
And as it cools, its
temperature will change.
But if you account for
the changing temperature,
it will be true at
anytime, actually.
But the temperature will change.
AUDIENCE: Because,
in the black cavity,
it has things exciting it.
And when you take
it out, there's
no photons, no constant
radiation to excite it.
So it can radiate--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Once you take it out, it's
no longer being excited.
And I think, technically,
you're right.
Once you take it out,
it will not only cool,
but it will cease to be
at a uniform temperature.
And that's basically
what we're saying
if we're saying that the
atoms that are excited
won't necessarily be in the
right thermal distribution
as they would be if
it was on the inside.
That would be a
statement that is not
any longer in
thermal equilibrium.
But as long as the
radiation is slow,
you could just account for
the changing temperature.
You would know how it radiates.
And I think that's a
very good approximation.
Although in principle,
it will cease
to be in thermal equilibrium,
as soon as you take it out,
the edges will be cool,
and the center will be hot.
And you'd have to take into
account all of those things
to be able to understand
how it radiates.
Any other questions?
OK, next, I want to
talk a little bit
about what this
black-body radiation is.
And one can begin by
trying to understand
it purely classically,
which, of course,
is what happened historically.
In the 1800s, people tried to
understand cavity radiation
or black-body radiation using
classical physics, Maxwell's
equations, to describe
the radiation.
And then, in a
nutshell-- we're just
trying to establish
basic ideas here--
one can try to treat a field
statistical-mechanically
by imagining not
fields in empty space,
but fields in some
kind of a box.
In this case, it
doesn't necessarily
have to be the cavity
that we're talking about.
It could be a big box that just
enclosed the system somehow
to make it easier to talk about.
And in the end,
you could imagine
taking that box to infinity,
this theoretical box
that you use to
simplify the problem.
But once you put
the system in a box,
then a field, like the
electromagnetic field,
can always be broken
up into normal modes,
standing wave patterns that have
an integer or a half integer
number of wavelengths
inside the box.
And no matter how complicated
the field is inside the box,
you could always describe
it as a superposition
of some set of standing waves.
In general, it takes
an infinite number
of standing wave components
to describe an arbitrary
field-- that is, with shorter
and shorter wavelengths.
But you can always-- and
this is Fourier's theorem--
you can always
describe an arbitrary
field in terms of
the standing waves.
And that's good for
the point of view
of thinking about
statistical mechanics,
because you could think
about each standing wave
almost as if it were a particle.
It really is a
harmonic oscillator.
So if you think you know
the statistical mechanics
of harmonic oscillators,
each standing wave in the box
is just a harmonic
oscillator, so simple.
We now try to ask what
is the thermodynamics
of this system of
harmonic oscillators.
And the rule for harmonic
oscillator is simple.
Stat mech tells
you that you have
1/2 kT per degree of freedom
in thermal equilibrium.
The energy of a
system should just
be 1/2 kT per degree of freedom.
Having said that, all
the complicate questions
come about by asking
ourselves what
is meant by degree of freedom.
But for the harmonic oscillator,
that has a simple answer.
A harmonic oscillator
has two degrees
of freedom-- the kinetic energy
and the potential energy.
So the energy of a
harmonic oscillator
should just be kT per
degree of freedom.
And we could apply that to our
gas in the box and we could,
ask how much energy
should the gas absorb
at a given temperature?
What should be the energy
density of the gas at a given
temperature-- this
gas of photons.
But it was noticed in
the 1900-- the 1800s
that this doesn't work because
there's no limit to how short
the wavelengths can be.
And therefore, there's
not just some finite set
of harmonic oscillators.
There's an infinite
set of harmonic
oscillators where you have
more and more harmonic
oscillators at shorter
and shorter wavelengths
ad infinitum, no limit.
And that came to be
known as Jean's Paradox.
So what it suggests is that
if this classical stat mech
worked-- which obviously
it's not working.
But if it did
work, it would mean
that as you tried to put a gas
in just an empty box in contact
with something at a
fixed temperature,
the box would absorb more and
more energy without limit.
And ultimately, it
would presumably
cause the temperature
of the whatever
is trying to maintain
the temperature
to go to 0 as energy
gets siphoned off
to shorter and shorter
wavelengths of excitations.
That obviously isn't the
way the world behaves.
We'd all freeze to
death if it did.
So something has to
happen to save it.
And it wasn't at all
obvious for many years
what it was that saves it.
But this Jean's
Paradox turns out
to be saved by
quantum mechanics.
And the important implication
of quantum mechanics
is that the energy of
a harmonic oscillator
is no longer allowed to
have any possible value,
but is now quantized
as some integer times
h times nu, the
frequency-- h being
Planck's constant,
nu being frequency, n
being some integer where
this integer might be called
the excitation level of
the harmonic oscillator.
Depending how you choose your
0, you might have an n plus 1/2
there.
But that's not important
for us right now.
It will be important
later actually.
But for now, we'll just allow
ourselves to readjust the 0
and just think of it as n
times h nu, or h bar omega.
Now, this makes
all the difference,
statistical mechanically.
One can apply
statistical mechanics
using basically
the same principles
to the quantum
mechanical system.
And the key thing now is that
for the very short wavelengths,
which are the ones that
were giving us trouble--
the infinities came
to short wavelengths.
For the short wavelengths
where nu is high, h nu is high.
And it means that
there's a minimum ante
that you could put in to
excite those short wavelength
harmonic oscillators.
And it's a large number.
You either put in a large
amount of energy or none at all.
Quantum mechanics doesn't let
you do anything in between.
Now remember, the
classical mechanics answer
was that you have kT in
each harmonic oscillator.
And kT would be small
compared to h nu,
if we're talking about
a very short wavelength.
So the classic
answer is just not
allowed by quantum mechanics.
You either have to put in
nothing or an amount much, much
larger than the
classical answer.
And when you do the statistical
mechanics quantum mechanically,
which is not a big
deal really, you
find that when you're
confronted with that choice,
the most likely answer is
to put in no energy at all.
So quantum mechanics freezes out
these short wavelength modes.
And then the n produces
a finite energy density
for a gas of photons.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Seems like
if you were to sum over
like all the possible
wave numbers, that-- well,
so the energy is inversely
related to wavelength, right?
So even if you quantize it,
like for large wavelengths,
isn't the sum still like a sum
of one over lambda wavelength,
with its derivative?
PROFESSOR: You're
saying, isn't there also
a divergence at the
large wavelength n?
AUDIENCE: Because
that sum doesn't
seem like it would work.
PROFESSOR: Right.
No, that's important.
The reason that's
not a problem is
that if you're talking
about the energy in a box,
the wavelength can't
be bigger than the box.
The largest possible
wavelength is twice the box so
that half a wavelength
fits in the box.
If you're talking about the
energy in the whole infinite
universe, then we expect
the answer to infinite.
And it is.
There's no problem with
having infinite total energy
if you want to have
a finite energy
density throughout
an infinite universe.
So the size of the box cuts
off the large wavelengths.
And quantum mechanics cuts
off the small wavelengths.
So in the end, one does
get a finite answer
for the energy density
of black-body radiation.
And that's crucial
for our survival,
crucial for the
existence of the universe
as we know it, and also
crucial for the calculations
that we're about to do.
OK, so when one does these
calculations initially
for photons only, what we'd
find is that the energy density
is equal to a fudge factor,
which I'm going to call g.
And you'll see later why I'm
introducing a fudge factor.
For now, g is just 2.
But later, we'll generalize the
application of this formula,
and g will have
different values.
But for now, we're
dealing with photons.
There's a factor of 2 there,
but I'm going to write 2 as g,
writing g equals 2 underneath.
And then the pi
squared over 30--
you can really
calculate this-- times
kT to the fourth power divided
by h bar c cubed, h bar
being Plank's constant
divided by 2 pi and little k
being Boltzmann constant.
So this is calculated just by
thinking of the gas in a box
as a lot of harmonic oscillators
and applying standard stat
mech to each
harmonic oscillator,
but you apply the quantum
mechanical version of the stat
mech to each
harmonic oscillator.
And you can also find, by doing
the same kind of analysis,
that the pressure is
1/3 the energy density,
which we also derived
earlier by different means.
And it's all consistent so you
get the same answer every time,
even if you think
about it differently.
So here, I have mine deriving
it directly from the stat mech.
You can also, from
the stat mech,
calculate the number density of
photons in thermal equilibrium.
And that will be equal to --
again, there's a factor of 2.
But this time, I'll
call the factor
of 2 g star, where g star
also equals 2 for photons.
But when we generalize
these formulas,
g will not necessarily
equal g star,
which is why I'm
giving it two names.
And this g star
multiplies zeta of 3,
where zeta refers to the
Riemann zeta function, which
I'll define in a second,
divided by pi squared times
kT cubed divided
by h bar c cubed.
OK.
OK, so I need to
define this zeta of 3.
It's 1 over 1 cubed plus 1 over
2 cubed plus 1 over 3 cubed
plus dot dot dot.
It's an infinite series.
And if you sum up
that infinite series,
at least to three decimal
places, it's 1.202.
OK, then there's
one other formula
that will be of interest to us.
And that'll be a formula
for the entropy density.
Now, if you've had
a stat mech course,
you have some idea of what
entropy density means.
If you have not, suffice
it to say for this class
that it is some measure of
the disorder in the sense
of the total number of
different quantum states
that contribute to a given
macroscopic description.
The more different
microstates there
are that contribute to a
macroscopic description,
the higher the entropy.
And the other important
thing about entropy to us
besides that vague definition--
which will be enough--
but the important
thing for us is
that under most circumstances,
entropy will be conserved.
It's conserved as
long as things stay
at or near thermal equilibrium.
And in the early universe
as the universe expands,
that's the case.
So for us, the
entropy of our gas
will simply be a
conserved quantity
that we can make use of.
And we will make use of
it in some important ways.
And we could write
down a formula
for the entropy
density of photons.
And it's g, where this g in
fact the same g as over there.
It is related to the energy.
So it's the same g that
appears in two cases, 2
in both cases for
protons by themselves.
And then there are factors
that you can calculate--
2 pi squared over 45 times k to
the fourth T cubed over h bar
c cubed.
OK, this time, the number
of k's and T's do not match.
That's mainly due to
the conventions about
how entropy is defined.
It's not really anything deep.
I might mention at
this point that the 2's
that I've been writing for
everything-- g equals 2,
g star equals 2-- the
reason those 2's are written
explicitly rather than just
absorbing the factor of 2
into the other factors is
that photons are characterized
by the fact that there are
two polarizations of photons.
So if I have a beam
of photons, they
could be right-handed
or left-handed.
And anything else
could be considered
a superposition of those two.
So there are two
independent polarizations.
And it's useful to keep
track of these formulas
as the amount of energy
density per polarization.
Thus, different
kinds of particles
will have different
numbers of polarizations.
So if we know the
amount per polarization,
we'll be able to more easily
apply it to other particles.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, just to kind
of bring up the same question,
if we-- I read that
in the early universe,
the temperature is constantly
changing or it's cooling.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: So then if the
temperature is changing,
then how can we say that
the entropy is constant?
PROFESSOR: OK,
important question--
we'll be getting
to it very soon.
But since you asked the
question, I'll ask it now.
The question was if the
universe is expanding,
and the entropy
density is going down
because it thins,
how can that happen--
I guess it was asked
the other way around.
If the temperature
is falling, how
can entropy be
conserved if this is
the formula for entropy density?
And the answer-- when I tell
you, you'll see it's obvious.
We don't expect
the entropy density
to be conserved if the
entropy is conserved.
The entropy thins out
as the universe expands.
So if we just had a gas
with nothing else changing,
we expect the entropy density
to go down like 1 over the scale
factor cubed, just like the
number density of particles.
So if s is going to go down like
1 over the scale factor cubed,
that would be consistent
with this formula
if the temperature also fell
as 1 over the scale factor.
So that to cubing it
made things match.
And that's what we'll find.
The temperature falls off,
like 1 over the scale factor.
And that's consistent
with everything
that we said about energy
densities and so on.
OK.
Next thing I want
to talk about is
neutrinos, which
I told you earlier
contributes in a significant
way to the radiation energy
density in the universe today.
Neutrinos are particles
which for a long time,
were thought to be massless.
Until around 2000
or so, neutrinos
were thought to be massless.
Now we know that in fact, they
have a very small mass, which
complicates the
description here.
It turns out that
cosmologically, neutrinos
still act as if
they were massless
for almost all purposes
and for really all purposes
that we'll be dealing with in
this class, although if we were
interested in the effects
of neutrinos on structure
formation, we'd be
interested in whether or not
the neutrinos have a
small mass or whether it's
smaller than that.
We know it's non-zero.
We don't know what the
neutrino mass is, by the way.
What we actually know
from observations
is that there are three
types of neutrinos.
And those are called flavors.
And I'll use the letter
nu for the word neutrino.
And those three
types of neutrinos
are called nu sub e, called
the electron neutrino;
nu subbed mu, called the muon
neutrino, and nu sub tau,
called the tau neutrino.
And these letters e, mu, and tau
link to the names of particles.
This is the electron neutrino.
This is the muon
neutrino connected
to a particle called
the muon, which
is like the electron but
heavier and different.
And this is linked to a particle
called the tau, which is also
like the electron but much more
heavier but otherwise similar
in its properties.
And the neutrinos are
linked in the sense
that when a neutrino
is produced, depending
on how you start, it is
very typically produced
in conjunction with one
of these other particles.
So an electron
neutrino is typically
produced in conjunction
with an electron.
And similarly, a muon
neutrino is typically
produced in conjunction
with a muon.
And a tau neutrino is typically
produced in conjunction
with a tau.
Now, what does this have
to do with neutrino masses?
We've never actually measured
the mass of neutrino.
So we only know that they
have mass indirectly.
What we have seen is one
flavor of neutrino turn
into another flavor.
And it turns out, in the
context of quantum field theory
and I think this does make
a certain amount of sense
just by intuition, if
a particle is massless,
it can never change
into anything.
The process by which
one changes into another
is pretty quantum
mechanical and a little hard
to understand anyway.
But if the particles
were really massless,
they would move at
the speed of light.
And if the particles were
moving at the speed of light,
if the particle had any kind
of a clock on the particle,
that clock would literally
stop with the particle
moving at the speed of light.
So if particles are massless,
any internal workings
that that particle
might have to be frozen.
That is, if it's a
clock, it has to be
a clock that's
stopped completely.
And for reasons that
are essentially that,
although they can be made
more formal and more rigorous,
a truly massless
particle could never
undergo any kind
of change whatever.
It would have to
stay exactly like it
looks like to start with.
Because it just has no time.
So the fact that these
neutrinos turn into each other
implies that they must
have a nonzero mass.
It must not really be moving
at quite the speed of light.
And that's the way
the formalism works.
And we could set
limits on the masses
based on what we know about
the transitions between one
kind of neutrino and another.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do we
explain photon decaying
to an electron-positron
pair then?
PROFESSOR: A photon decaying
to an electron-positron pair?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: The answer is a
free photon never does decay
to an electron-positron pair.
Photons can collide
with something
and produce an
electron-positron pair.
But that collision, that's
a more complicated process.
What I'm saying is-- I'm sorry.
This process of conversion--
maybe I should have clarified--
happens just as the
neutrinos travel.
It's not due to collisions.
Due to collsions,
complicated things
can happen whether the
particle is massless or not.
But a massless particle simply
in transit cannot undergo any
kind of transition.
And these neutrinos are seen
to undergo transitions simply
being in transit
without any collisions.
In terms of my clock
analogy and a stopped clock,
I think the reason
the photon can convert
into electron-positron pairs
if it collides with something
is that when it collides, it
essentially breaks the clock.
You don't have a
photon that's just
moving along without
time anymore.
OK, so these
neutrinos have masses.
And maybe I should,
at this point,
write down some bounds
on these masses.
m squared 21 times c to the
fourth is equal to 7.50 plus
or minus 0.2 times 10 to the
minus 5 electron volts squared.
These numbers come from the
latest particle data tables,
which I gave references
for in the notes.
So this is the difference
of the mass squared.
And delta m 23 squared
times c to the fourth
to turn it into the
square of an energy
is 2.32 plus 0.12
minus 0.08 times 10
to the minus third
electron volts squared.
So one thing you
notice immediately
is that these are
incredibly small masses.
Remember, the proton
weighs 938 MeV,
three million electron volts.
And these are fractions
of one electron volt.
So by the standards
of particle physics,
these are unbelievably
small energies,
unbelievably small
mass differences.
But they're there.
They have to be there for the
physics we know to make sense.
The other thing
that you may notice
about this notation-- which
I don't want to elaborate
on but I'll just mention--
this is called 21.
This is called 23.
There's no 1, 2, or 3 there.
There's an e and a mu and a tau.
The complication here is
something very quantum
mechanical.
The e, mu and tau
labels are labels
which basically label
the neutrino according
to how the neutrino is created.
It turns out that their mass
eigenstates-- states which
actually have a
definite mass-- are not
the e, the mu or the tau.
In fact, if the e
had a definite mass,
that would be saying
that an e would just
propagate as a particle
with a certain mass.
It would not convert
into anything else.
The fact that an e converts
into other particles--
a nu sub e converts
into other particles
is really the statement
that nu sub e is not
a state with a definite mass.
But there are states
with definite masses
which could be expressed quantum
mechanically as superpositions
of these flavor eigenstates.
So nu sub 1, nu
sub 2 and nu sub 3
are states of neutrinos
that have definite masses.
And each one of them is
a superposition of nu sub
e, nu sub mu and nu sub tau.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How come we don't
have a delta n from 31?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
I think it's just the
lack of knowledge.
I don't think there's any
reason it's not defined.
I'm sure it is defined.
I think it's just
lack of knowledge.
And if I knew more details about
how these things were measured,
I could give you a
better story about that.
But I don't, frankly.
So in the end, it's a rather
complicated quantum mechanical
system which we're not going
to go into any details about.
What more should I say today?
OK, let me just
mention for today
and we'll continue next
time after the quiz,
for our purposes, we're going
to treat these neutrinos
as if they're massless.
And it turns out that that's
actually extraordinarily
accurate from the point
of view of cosmology,
at least for the
kind of cosmology
that we're doing
where we're just
interested in the effect
of these neutrinos
on the expansion
rate of the universe.
And treating them as
massless particles,
I will shortly give
you the formulas
for how they contribute to
the black-body radiation.
But it I think there's no
point in my writing them now.
I'll just write them again in
the beginning of next period.
But they do contribute to
the black-body radiation
and in a way that we actually
know how to calculate.
And they have a
noticeable effect
on the evolution
of our universe.
OK, that's all for today.
Good luck on the
quiz on Thursday.
I'll be here to help proctor.
I think Tim [INAUDIBLE]
will be here too.
And I'll see you more intimately
either at my office hour
tomorrow or at lecture
a week from now.